жорсткі правила, але ми будемо
вже переконатися, що вони всі
отримати приблизно стільки ж часу для розмови
ми повинні інвестувати набагато більше
Проте я маю на увазі, що це було тоді
невеликий діалог зеленого кольору
з Росією це означає, що ми навіть капітулюємо
немає шансів, що хороше міжнародне право
розрив, який ми не можемо прийняти
не можна вирішити в короткостроковій перспективі він і
у мене важкий аргумент
про російську політику я його
З одного боку, нас мало
послідовно по відношенню до росії маємо
досі конвеєрні проекти Мартін Шульц хоче
американські ядерні бомби
вивести Німеччину, хоча Путін масово
оновив і з іншого
сторона, з якою у нас занадто мало діалогу
Росія, це означає, що ми не поступаємося
шанс, що Путін вийшов із глухого кута
виходить, тому що ми всі
зробити питання залежним
хоча всі знають, що цей
ми не порушуємо міжнародне право
не може прийняти в короткостроковій перспективі
можна вирішити
Оздемір сказав мені, що сприймає це серйозно
Я ношу або зараз вона приходить зараз
приходить струмком, сказав він мені
Можливо, я надто поблажливий
протилежність путіну
тому я хочу запитати його як
постійно він проти Путіна – це я
Я за Німеччину, вільну від ядерної зброї
і Європа вільна від ядерної зброї
ядерна зброя – це добре
успіх повідомлення дуже добре для
вони вам не потрібні, їх потрібно відрахувати
я хочу цього, але це дає мені
хороший шаблон, дорогий християнин
Ленднер Будапештський меморандум
робили в той час після розпаду в
залізна завіса для таких країн
Україна гарантована, якщо ваш
лом ядерної зброї
Україна зголосилася
пояснює всю їхню ядерну зброю
відмовившись від арсеналу, він буде вашим
обмеження гарантовано, дорогий християнино
Питання Лінднера, а як щодо межі
в Україні сталося
Росія анексувала частину
похмурий схід україни
Я взагалі нічого не чув
окупований російськими військами
стабілізувався, що є уроком для
світова більш-менш ядерна зброя
зараз багато країн в
Світ скажіть собі, коли ви дивитесь на це
слово росія сша інше ні
може виїхати з україни це що
право в європі для загального
запровадити достатньо жорсткі санкції
може стати більшою кількістю країн-членів
подивіться як угорщина та ін
це вірно ми могли знати тоді
навіть винагороди за це немає
свою країну у відкриту в'язницю
трансформувався, і, до речі, це також повинно бути
ліберальне знання
в Європі намагалися масово в
вибори заважають шансам і телеком
також продають в сільській місцевості
а саме в тому, що у вас є школа
добре, вони можуть допомогти, але одне
закінчення школи
ми багато зробили для розширення
чи можу я зазначити, що ми маємо в
вручити ситуацію
спочатку була телекомунікаційною
податок країн Терезів